YOUR SCREEN WITH THE BEARD.
THERE IS PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY ABOUT TO BE
INTRODUCED.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> MEMBERS --
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS, I HAVE THE HIGH
PRIVILEGE AND THE DISTINCT HONOR
OF PRESENTING TO YOU HIS
EXCELLENCY VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY,
PRESIDENT OF THE UKRAINE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH
.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S TOO MUCH FOR ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ALL THIS FOR OUR GREAT PEOPLE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DEAR AMERICANS, IN ALL STATES,
CITIES, AND COMMUNITIES, ALL
THOSE WHO VALUE FREEDOM AND
JUSTICE, WHO CHEER US AS
STRONGLY AS WE UKRAINIANS IN OUR
CITIES IN EACH AND EVERY FAMILY,
I HOLD MY WORDS OF RESPECT AND
GRATITUDE RESONATE IN EACH
AMERICAN HEART.
MADAM VICE PRESIDENT, I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS IN HELPING
UKRAINE, MADAM SPEAKER.
YOU BRAVELY VISITED UKRAINE
DURING THE FULL-FLEDGED WAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I AM VERY PRIVILEGED TO BE HERE.
DEAR MEMBERS OF THE CONGRESS,
REPRESENTATIVES OF BOTH PARTIES
WHO ALSO VISITED KYIV, ESTEEMED
CONGRESSMEN AND SENATORS FROM
BOTH PARTIES WHO WILL VISIT
UKRAINE, I AM SURE IN THE
FUTURE.
DEAR REPRESENTATIVES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ACROSS THIS CHAMBER AND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, DEAR JOURNALISTS,
IT'S A GREAT HONOR FOR ME TO BE
AT THE U.S. CONGRESS AND SPEAK
TO YOU AND ALL AMERICANS.
AGAINST ALL ODDS AND DOOM AND
GLOOM SCENARIOS, UKRAINE DIDN'T
FALL.
UKRAINE IS ALIVE AND KICKING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
AND IT GIVES ME GOOD REASON TO
SHARE WITH YOU OUR FIRST JOINT
VICTORY.
WE DEFEATED RUSSIA IN THE BATTLE
FOR MINES OF THE WORLD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
WE HAVE NO FEAR, NOR SHOULD
ANYONE IN THE WORLD HAVE IT.
UKRAINE'S GAINED THIS VICTORY,
AND IT GIVES US COURAGE WHICH
INSPIRES THE ENTIRE WORLD.
AMERICANS GAINED THIS VICTORY.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE
SUCCEEDED IN UNITING THE GLOBAL
COMMUNITY TO PROTECT FREEDOM AND
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
EUROPEANS GAINED THIS VICTORY,
AND THAT'S WHY EUROPE IS NOW
STRONGER AND MORE INDEPENDENT
THAN EVER.
THE RUSSIAN TYRANNY HAS LOST
CONTROL OVER US.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND IT WILL NEVER INFLUENCE OUR
MINDS AGAIN.
YET, WE HAVE TO DO WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO ENSURE THAT CONGRESS
ALSO GAIN SUCH VICTORY.
I KNOW ONE MORE I THINK VERY
IMPORTANT THING.
THE RUSSIANS WILL STAND A CHANCE
TO BE FREE ONLY WHEN THEY DEFEAT
THE KREMLIN, IN THEIR MINDS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
YET, THE BATTLE CONTINUES, AND
WE HAVE TO DEFEAT THE KREMLIN ON
THE BATTLEFIELD, YES.
THESE BATTLES NOT ONLY FOR THE
TERRITORY, THE BATTLE IS NOT
ONLY FOR LIFE, FREEDOM, AND
SECURITY OF UKRAINIANS OR ANY
OTHER NATION WHICH RUSSIA
ATTEMPTS TO CONQUER.
THE STRUGGLE WILL DEFINE IN WHAT
WORLD OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN WILL LIVE, AND
THEN THEIR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN.
IT WILL DEFINE WHETHER IT WILL
BE A DEMOCRACY OF UKRAINIANS AND
FOR AMERICANS FOR ALL.
THIS BATTLE CANNOT BE FROZEN OR
POSTPONED.
IT CANNOT BE IGNORED HOPING THAT
THE OCEAN OR SOMETHING ELSE WILL
PROVIDE A PROTECTION FROM THE
UNITED STATES TO CHINA, FROM
EUROPE TO LATIN AMERICA, AND
FROM AFRICA TO AUSTRALIA, THE
WORLD IS TOO INTERCONNECTED AND
INTERDEPENDENT TO ALLOW SOMEONE
TO STAND ASIDE AND AT THE SAME
TIME TO FEEL SAFE WHEN SUCH A
BATTLE CONTINUES.
OUR TWO NATIONS ARE ALLIES IN
THIS BATTLE.
AND NEXT YEAR WILL BE IMPORTANT,
AT THE POINT WHEN UKRAINIAN
COURAGE AND AMERICAN RESOLVE
MUST GUARANTEE THE FUTURE OF OUR
COMMON FREEDOM, THE FREEDOM OF
PEOPLE WHO STAND FOR THEIR
VALUES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, AMERICANS,
YESTERDAY BEFORE COMING HERE TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., I WAS AT THE
FRONT LINE IN BAKHMUT.
IN OUR STRONG HOLD IN THE EAST
OF UKRAINE IN THE DONBAS.
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY AND
MACHINERS HAVE BEEN TAKING
BAKHMUT NONSTOP SINCE MAY.
THEY HAVE BEEN TAKING IT DAY AND
NIGHT, BUT BAKHMUT STANDS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
LAST YEAR, 70,000 PEOPLE LIVED
HERE IN BAKHMUT IN THIS CITY.
NOW ONLY A FEW CIVILIANS STAY.
EVERY INCH OF THAT LAND IS
SOAKED IN BLOOD, ROARING GUNS
SOUND EVERY HOUR.
DONBAS CHANGED HANDS SEVERAL
TIME IN FIERCE COMBAT, AND EVEN
HAND-FIGHTING.
BUT THE UKRAINIAN DONBAS STANDS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
RUSSIANS USE EVERYTHING,
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE AGAINST
BAKHMUT AND OTHER OF OUR
BEAUTIFUL CITIES, THE OCCUPIERS
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGE IN
ARTILLERY.
THEY HAVE AN ADVANTAGE IN
AMMUNITION.
THEY HAVE MUCH MORE MISS MISS
AISLES AND PLANES THAN WE EVER
HAD.
IT'S TRUE.
BUT OUR DEFENSE FORCES STAND.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND WE ALL ARE PROUD OF THEM.
THE RUSSIANS' TACTIC IS
PRIMITIVE.
THEY BURN DOWN AND DESTROY
EVERYTHING THEY SEE.
THEY SENT CONVICTS TO THE FRONT
LINES, TO THE WAR.
THEY THREW EVERYTHING AGAINST
SIMILAR TO THE OTHER TYRANNY,
WHICH IS IN THE BATTLE OF THE
BULGE.
THROUGH EVERYTHING IT HAD
AGAINST THE FREE WORLD, JUST
LIKE THE BRAVE AMERICAN SOLDIERS
WHICH HELD THEIR LINES AND
FOUGHT BACK HITLER'S FORCES
DURING THE CHRISTMAS OF 1944.
BRAVE UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS ARE
DOING THIS SAME TO PUTIN'S
FORCES THIS CHRISTMAS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
UKRAINE HOLDS ITS LINES AND WILL
NEVER SURRENDER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO, HERE THE FRONT LINE, THE
TYRANNY WHICH HAS NO LACK OF
CRUELTY AGAINST THE LIVES OF
FREE PEOPLE, AND YOUR SUPPORT IS
CRUCIAL NOT JUST TO STAND IN
SUCH FIGHT BUT TO GET TO THE
TURNING POINT TO WIN ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
WE HAVE ARTILLERY, YES.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE IT.
IS IT ENOUGH?
HONESTLY, NOT REALLY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
TO ENSURE BAKHMUT, NO JUSTICE,
BUT FOR THE RUSSIAN ARMY TO
COMPLETELY PULL OUT MORE CANNONS
AND SHELLS ARE NEEDED.
JUST LIKE THE BATTLE OF SARA
TOGA, THE FIGHT FOR BAKHMUT WILL
CHANGE THE TRAGIC STORY OF OUR
WAR FOR INDEPENDENCE AND OF
FREEDOM.
IF YOUR PATRIOTS STOP THE
RUSSIAN TERROR AGAINST OUR
CITIES IT WILL LET UKRAINIAN
WORK TO THE FULL TO DEFEND OUR
FREEDOM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
WHEN RUSSIA -- WHEN RUSSIA
CANNOT REACH OUR CITIES BY ITS
ARTILLERY, IT TRIES TO DESTROY
THEM WITH MISSILE ATTACKS.
MORE THAN THAT RUSSIA FOUND AN
ALLY IN THIS GENOCIDAL POLICY,
IRAN.
IRANIAN DEADLY DRONES SENT TO
RUSSIA IN HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
BECAME A THREAT TO OUR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT IS HOW ONE TERRORIST HAS
FOUND THE OTHER.
IT IS JUST A MATTER OF TIME WHEN
THEY WILL STRIKE AGAINST YOUR
OTHER ALLIES IF WE DO NOT STOP
THEM NOW.
WE MUST DO IT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I BELIEVE IN US AND OUR
ALLIANCE.
UKRAINE NEVER ASKED THE AMERICAN
SOLD ATTORNEYS FIGHT ON OUR LAND
INSTEAD OF US.
I ASSURE YOU THAT UKRAINIAN
SOLDIERS CAN PERFECTLY OPERATE
AMERICAN TANKS AND PLANES
THEMSELVES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE IS ALSO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, THANK YOU FOR BOTH
FINANCIAL PACKAGES YOU HAVE
ALREADY PROVIDED US WITH AND THE
ONES YOU MAY BE WILLING TO
DECIDE ON.
YOUR MONEY IS NOT CHARITY.
IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN THE GLOBAL
SECURITY AND DEMOCRACY THAT WE
HANDLE IN THE MOST RESPONSIBLE
WAY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
RUSSIA, RUSSIA COULD STOP ITS
AGGRESSION, REALLY IF IT WANTED
TO, BUT YOU CAN SPEED UP OUR
VICTORY.
I KNOW IT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND IT -- AND IT WILL PROVE TO
ANY POTENTIAL AGGRESSOR THAT NO
ONE CAN SUCCEED IN BREAKING
NATIONAL BORDERS, NO ONE
COMMITTING ATROCITIES AND IT
WOULD BE NAIVE TO WAIT TOWARDS
STEPS FOR PEACE BY RUSSIA WHICH
ENJOYS BEING A TERRORIST STATE.
RUSSIANS ARE STILL POISONED BY
THE KREMLIN.
IT IS OUR JOINT TASK.
WE NEED PEACE, YES.
UKRAINE HAS ALREADY OFFERED
PROPOSALS WHICH I JUST DISCUSSED
WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN, OUR PEACE
FORMULA, TEN POINTS WHICH SHOULD
AND MUST BE IMPLEMENTED FOR OUR
JOINT SECURITY, GUARANTEED FOR
DECADES AHEAD AND THE SUMMIT
WHICH CAN BE HELD.
I'M GLAD TO SAY THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN SUPPORTED OUR PEACE
INITIATIVE TODAY.
EACH OF YOU, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, CAN ASSIST IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION TO ENSURE THAT
AMERICANS' LEADERSHIP REMAINS
SOLID, BICAMERAL AND BIPARTISAN.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
YOU CAN STRENGTHEN SANCTIONS TO
MAKE RUSSIA FEEL HOW RUINOUS ITS
AGGRESSION TRULY IS.
IT IS IN YOUR POWER, REALLY, TO
HELP US BRING TO JUSTICE
EVERYONE WHO STARTED THIS
UNPROVOKED AND CRIMINAL WAR.
LET'S DO IT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
LET TERRORISTS --
LET THE TERRORISTS STATE BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS AGGRESSION
AND COMPENSATE ALL LOSSES DONE
BY THIS WAR.
LET THE WORLD SEE THAT THE
UNITED STATES ARE HERE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, AMERICANS, IN TWO
DAYS WE WILL CELEBRATE
CHRISTMAS.
MAYBE CANDLELIT.
NOT BECAUSE IT'S MORE ROMANTIC,
NO, BUT BECAUSE THERE WILL NOT
BE -- THERE WILL BE NO
ELECTRICITY.
MILLIONS WANT, HAVE NEITHER
HITTING NOUR RUNNING WATER.
ALL OF THESE WILL BE THE RESULT
OF RUSSIAN MISSILE AND DRONE
ATTACKS ON OUR ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT WE DO NOT COMPLAIN.
WE DO NOT JUDGE AND COMPARE
WHOSE LIFE IS EASIER, YOUR
WELL-BEING IS THE PRODUCT OF
YOUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
THE RESULT OF YOUR STRUGGLE FOR
INDEPENDENCE AND YOUR MANY
VICTORIES.
WE, UKRAINIANS, WILL ALSO GO
THROUGH OUR WAR OF INDEPENDENCE
AND FREEDOM WITH DIGNITY AND
SUCCESS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
WE'LL CELEBRATE CHRISTMAS,
CELEBRATE CHRISTMAS AND EVEN IF
THERE IS NO ELECTRICITY, THE
LIGHT OF OUR FAITH IN OURSELVES
WILL NOT BE PUT OUT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
IF RUSSIAN -- IF RUSSIAN
MISSILES ATTACK US WE'LL DO OUR
BEST TO PROTECT OURSELVES.
IF THEY ATTACK US WITH IRANIAN
DRONES AND OUR PEOPLE WILL HAVE
TO GO TO BOMB SHELTERS ON
CHRISTMAS EVE, UKRAINIANS WILL
STILL SIT DOWN AT THE HOLIDAY
TABLE AND CHEER UP EACH OTHER
AND WE DON'T, DON'T HAVE TO KNOW
EVERYONE'S WISH AS WE KNOW THAT
ALL OF US, MILLIONS OF
UKRAINIANS, WISH THE SAME,
VICTORY.
ONLY VICTORY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
WE ALREADY BUILT STRONG UKRAINE
WITH STRONG PEOPLE, STRONG ARMY,
STRONG INSTITUTIONS TOGETHER
WITH YOU.
WE DEVELOPED STRONG SECURITY
GUARANTEES FOR OUR COUNTRY AND
FOR ENTIRE EUROPE AND THE WORLD
TOGETHER WITH YOU AND ALSO
TOGETHER WITH YOU, WE'LL PUT IN
PLACE EVERYONE WHO WILL DEFY
FREEDOM.
PUT-IN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THIS WILL BE THE BASIS TO
PROTECT DEMOCRACY IN EUROPE AND
THE WORLD OVER, NOW, ON THIS
SPECIAL CHRISTMASTIME I WANT TO
THANK YOU, ALL OF YOU, I THANK
EVERY AMERICAN FAMILY, WHICH
CHERISHES THE WARMTH OF ITS HOME
AND WISHES THE SAME WARMTH TO
OTHER PEOPLE.
I THANK PRESIDENT BIDEN AND BOTH
PARTIES, AT THE SENATE AND THE
HOUSE, FOR YOUR INVALUABLE
ASSISTANCE.
I THANK YOUR CITIES AND YOUR
CITIZENS WHO SUPPORTED UKRAINE
THIS YEAR, WHO HOSTED OUR
UKRAINIANS, OUR PEOPLE, WHO
WAVED OUR NATIONAL FLAGS, WHO
ACTED TO HELP US, THANK, THANK
YOU ALL FROM EVERYONE WHO IS NOW
AT THE FRONT LINE FROM EVERYONE
WHO IS EVADING VICTORY.
STANDING HERE TODAY I RECALL THE
WARS OF THE PRESIDENT FRANKLIN
DELANO ROOSEVELT WHICH I CHOSE
FOR THIS MOMENT, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, IN THEIR MIGHT, WILL WIN
THROUGH -- TO ABSOLUTE VICTORY.
THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE WILL WIN
TOO ABSOLUTELY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I KNOW THAT EVERYTHING DEPENDS
ON US, ON UKRAINIAN ARMED FORCES
YET SO MUCH DEPENDS ON THE WORLD
SO MUCH IN THE WORLD DEPENDS ON
YOU.
WHEN I WAS IN BAKHMUT YESTERDAY,
OUR HEROES GAVE ME THE FLAG, THE
BATTLE FLAG, THE FLAG OF THOSE
WHO DEFEND UKRAINE, EUROPE AND
THE WORLD AT THE COST OF THEIR
LIVES.
THEY ASK ME TO BRING THIS FLAG
TO YOU, TO THE U.S. CONGRESS TO
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND SENATORS
WHOSE DECISIONS CAN SAVE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE, SO LET THIS
DECISION BE TAKEN, LET THIS FLAG
STAY WITH YOU, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
THIS FLAG IS A SYMBOL OF OUR
VICTORY IN THIS WAR.
WE STAND, WE FIGHT AND WE WILL
WIN BECAUSE WE ARE UNITED,
UKRAINE, AMERICA AND THE ENTIRE
FREE WORLD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> JUST ONE THING, IF I CAN, THE
LAST THING, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MAY GOD PROTECT OUR BRAVE TROOPS
AND CITIZENS, MAY GOD FOREVER
BLESS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, MERRY CHRISTMAS AND
HAPPY VICTORIOUS NEW YEAR.
[ SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
>> I CAN HOLD.
>> TURN IT AROUND.
THERE WE GO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THIS FLAG WAS FLOWN OVER THE
CAPITAL TODAY IN HONOR OF THE
PRESIDENT'S VISIT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]